Did you see the Oscars man?
I watched parasite and I loved that movie,
but I thought the main good thing about that movie was the, uh, the screenplay.
Um, and I thought it was directed great. And all the acting was really great.
And I liked the movie. Um,
and then this guy tweeted this thing about,
it's such a bad tweet.
John Miller is at Miller stream,
a man named bong Joon ho wins Oscar for best original screenplay over once upon
a time in Hollywood in 1917, acceptance speech was great honor. Thank you.
Then he proceeds to give the rest of his speech in the Korean.
These people are the destruction of America.
That's so bad to say,
you know, like just straight up, what are you saying? Hey dude,
trying to date you're on graph.
See.
It's interesting that like,
Trump has really brought these out, you know, bring them out,
bring them out. That's what they'd be yelling when the barrels in the mouth,
when you know that song, that Z song and never knew what he was saying.
Barela was like Burrell. He's saying barrel. I wish he just said that's what?
Just say saying when the bevel is in your mouth, why doesn't he do that? Why?
I don't know. Why does he say I, I need to like Hindus no way.
Why does he say that in a song? Don't know, but he does.
Yeah. Since secure,
always how he laughs it's all. Okay.
I ain't need to like, Intuit's no way anyway.
Um, so without the Jews,
that's why the Jews bought out a property
should have bought a property in Dumbo,
but I didn't because the Jews bought it and now I'm kicking myself
Hayne until I can do. It's no way. Um,
so yeah. And then I wrote
J Jesus. I wrote, well,
there's a ridiculous tweet. Jesus Christ. Um,
it's weird to think like extremely left.
And then also it's weird to think extremely, right? Like,
and then you see people like what's that girl's name?
Brin who's the girl who played captain Marvel.
And she's just like a guy looked at me now and you're like, okay,
let's just meet in the middle. I, you know,
or, or, or walking Phoenix acceptance speech where he's just like,
thanks for the Oscar. Don't drink milk Casey. Yeah.
Takes thanks for the Oscar. Thanks for the Oscar. Stop. Squeezing cows. Casey,
ya pivot peel. Whether we're talking,
there's a part where he was like,
whether we're talking about black people or cows, like, and how,
how do we not miss that too? Like,
it's all because we love occupants who is a super talented guy.
And obviously his heart is in the right place.
And obviously he's such a great guy just cares about lots of.
But like if I went up there, like if I've, if I,
for some reason went up and was just
like, guys, thanks so much for the Oscar. This is amazing.
But also black people and cows need rights. You'd be like,
Kay, we shouldn't have gave him the Oscar,
whether we're talking about Koreans or animals. Like,
how did we miss that? It's because dude, you give people,
they make a, they make a, they like, if the rock said it,
it will be okay. If a comedian said, they'd be done, dude,
if Rogan or anybody went up there and just were like said what? He said,
they'd be like, why is he comparing black people like cows?
Cool.
Um, these acceptance speeches are just,
I love walking Phoenix and I'm not even talking about his,
but these acceptance speeches are just so awful.
You know,
once they get to that point you're Oh great. Oh great.
No, but I'd like to thank this person, that person I'd like to take that.
And you know, once they get to that point, you're like, Oh, here it comes.
The distraction of the N Oh boy. And the thing is in the rights.
And if you we've got war and Oh,
you are wearing a $170,000 dress.
Okay, bye.
[Inaudible].
What if he just really went up and said, you know, he walked up and said,
thank you so much black people in cows need rights and in
it. Nah, nah, you ain't. Ain't
[inaudible] next up that even the guy who does the next up. Okay. Oh,
okay. Well next up
Colin Firth gunna gives you a war.
Whole boy gives you award for best picture.
That's him doing King's speech for those of you that haven't heard the God.
So this I should've just called this podcast sounds.
Um, so yeah, man, these, I don't know. I don't know how,
but, but, but this guy w what,
why do I understand the problem with a bong Joon, ho
Winning and then saying, great honor. Thank you.
And then these people destruction of America,
he went on to tweet John Miller went on to tweet.
These people are obviously not Koreans, but those in Hollywood of warning of,
for a foreign film, that Stokes flames of class warfare over two films,
I thought were more deservingly, simply reserving,
simply to show how woke they are.
Oh.
That should be clear from the rest of what I tweeted about tonight's production,
you know?
Okay.
Okay, man, you don't vote for.
That. Okay.
You're the host of something on blaze TV.
Yeah. No.
I think, um, I don't know who this guy is, whatever fine. I'm sure.
Maybe his heart's in the right place. I have no idea, but sounds bad.
Tweet sounds bad. Um, also,
if you're going to argue anything about any screenplay,
that was that to me and I, I didn't see all the movies,
but that was that movies. Screenplay was so good.
If you have a gripe with that movie and it's the screenplay,
I don't know where your head is, man.
It's also not like to say that he won because Hollywood is woke.
I guess maybe why? Cause he's Korean, I guess. I don't know. Weird,
weird that he's saying that weird, these picking that battle. I think,
cause that movie was awesome. And how cute was the guy who won it? When he won,
he was just like, Oh, Oh, Oh, Oh.
And then he was like talking about all the other guys who are winning,
who he was like Martin Scorsese. You know,
I can't believe I'm standing here with you or whatever the you said.
I don't know. It doesn't matter. But it was cute as, man.
God, that guy looks so polite.
Bong, Joon ho looks so polite.
He looks like he's never eaten something and gone. Yeah.
Even if it was gross, he's so polite.
Like he for sure eats at people's houses. And he was like,
what a wonderful meal the whole time. No matter what it is, they'd be like,
this is a car. This is, this is the cardboard,
this is, this is cardboard. And he's like, Oh, I'm gonna order it from you.
That's how he looks. Have you guys seen the host? It's so good.
And uh, Snowpiercer is so good. That movie should have been
you guys gotta see Snowpiercer it's so good with Chris Evans.
Um, but I got it.
I wish I could see that movie again. I never watched movies twice. that dude.
One time in high school, my buddy wanted to see,
he saw Braveheart and every time people come over and watch Braveheart and I was
like, dude, you watch them. We watch it one time.
And how you go through that again.
Braveheart of all movies to watch over and over again. It's wrong with you?
I guess his Dick cut off at the end. Ruined it. Spoiler alert.
Or maybe they cut his Tommy open. You never really know actually
Timothy Charlemagne. I liked Timothy Charlemagne man.
Definitely call it chill. I'm it? Timothy [inaudible].
But uh, look at this, this,
this that look news, AAV club.
Nobody knows what to do with Tim and the Shalon maze, Oscar look, huh?
He just put on him. He wore a track suit, dude.
That's the that he's I liked that he's doing that man. Cause it's so annoying.
Everyone gets all dressed up and everyone's so annoying.
I brought some of these dresses. They got to stand out.
Who was the girl that wore the hood. She looked like a star Wars, character,
Janell Monae. Is that her name? And it's like,
every time it showed the audience, my eye went right to her. It's like.
Oh, how about spite
LA? Yeah.
He wore a purple and yellow tox with 24 on
the lapel for Kobe Bryant. Hey dude.
And a driver's cap. And it did didn't he, he,
uh, he made it, he uh, did a, um, what did he present? What did he present?
Whatever you presented, the guy came up and it was like so beautiful.
I think it was bond June or whatever the guy's name is. He won. And then,
and then he walked off.
The moment, uh,
ruined the moment, you know, looked off fall.
So bits with the hate, love there's a picture of it with the hate, love, uh,
bear brass knuckles. And he's doing it like this.
It's a with the Kobe Bryant journey, by the way, Coby. Right? If you saw that,
he would be like, uh, what's doing to dune dude.
It's for a conch. You can do it. But to dune, like
people think they really out here saying just because they have hate and love on
their that's hilarious, man. What are you? What, what,
Oh, you're both those hate and love Keiko. Anyway, dude, you know,
we have to say about that.
That's as far as you looking for exactly.
Yeah. That was the word I was looking for. Did you know that? Um,
my brother's texting me. He hears he's like, here's a cut of your special.
And then he re he, because I told him to make a few changes and he says, come,
my brother directed my special. And he says,
he sent me the link and he writes here's the password, check it out.
And he writes it's perfect. So don't say it's not,
You know, dude, summat delayer um,
you should listen to my brother's podcast. It's really good. It's called, uh,
Matt Lee is confused. Uh,
this is, this is still my, uh, this is still my favorite, uh,
Oscar thing here that has happened was when John
Travolta.
God dude was when John Travolta did
miss messed up Idina Menzel name.
Let me break this down.
And always be a special place in my heart for the movie musical.
And for the songs that create.
It's going so well is my face is my favorite part.
Like he's going like legitimately swimmingly, like he's killing it.
He's very eloquent.
He's got his hairpiece on and it's looking natch and he's got his cool talks on.
Memorable moments here to perform the Oscar nominated gorgeously empowering
song. Let it go. Great word from the Oscar winning.
This is when he really knows he's starting to kill it too right here.
When he says wickedly.
Movie frozen, please welcome the wickedly talented one.
And only, uh.
The wickedly talented one and only this is what I think went on in his head
right now. He's forgetting how to pronounce her name. He knows it and he thinks,
you know what,
I'm going to use all my confidence and I'm going to start it with the word
wickedly and own my. And by the time I get to our name, it's going to come out.
Right. Because I've said it before and then it doesn't.
And that to me honestly.
Does the [inaudible].
That moment look at the frame when he's looking to his left, he's just like,
okay, well I it up.
And that moment was the moment where you know how you've
seen John Travolta bald a lot lately. He was just like, ah, it. I, you know, um,
that moment I guarantee that moment was what made him realize I don't need to
wear a hairpiece, uh, this. You know, I mean, bro,
he, I mean the buildup.
The smile special place in my heart, ready, movie musical, killing it.
And for the songs that create their most memorable moments here to perform the
Oscar nominated gorgeously empowering song, let it go.
He realizes he can't remember her name. When he says gorgeous.
Let it go from the Oscar winning animated movie,
frozen empowering song.
Let it go from the memorable moments here to perform the Oscar
nominated gorgeous, the impact.
It was Gordy gorgeously. Cause he had something else on his mind.
It was like a little too long to say gorgeous. And then, and then he was like,
it. I don't know what it is this whole time. And then when he unused my coffee,
that's the confidence kicking in and then it didn't have it though.
[inaudible] literally just say Frank Drebin you know what I mean? it.
It would been way better. Why do you say Frank? Drebin he'd be like, Oh,
I was thinking about, uh,
naked gun Lieutenant Drebin please welcome Lieutenant Drebin.
That would have been amazing.
And then everyone would have clapped still and you would be like you still
clapped at least own it like that. Oh, don't ever stutter. Syllables.
Just pick a new name and say please welcome Lieutenant Frank
Drebin and then.
Let it go. Let it go.
That's so great. Uh, Dell Desi seems, you know,
Oh, his kids were like, Oh no. Um,
but the other one was good. The other,
another one was good at the end with James Cameron. When he, when he,
when he wins for Titanic with the tales, you know,
built the, uh, deep diving camera system when he does this, uh, my lovely wife,
Linda nice are two beautiful children and Joseph's well,
he was married to Linda Hamilton. I didn't know that
originally. My parents who are here tonight, Phillip,
Phillip and Shirley Cameron, mom, dad.
There's no way I can express to you what I'm feeling right
now. My heart is full to bursting except to say that.
[Inaudible].
My whole thing don't will never will. My whole thing is never Whoa.
And he goes, I'm the King of the wild and that's one of those God,
it's amazing. These guys who's I mean, one of the, I mean,
so talented makes creates these worlds and then they just get up on stage and
you can see they're not used to it and they're a little bit nervous.
And then just, it's funny too,
being a standup comedian helps so much just in life, man. It just helps so much.
You don't give a about stuff. Like you could tell. He was like, Oh,
this seems like a better idea in my head when I cause it's a line in the movie.
And then when he said it he's like gone, maybe it's insecure, but it's like,
if you were a comedian and you did it and you were out there and you went,
I'm the King of the world. You're like, Oh this is a bad idea.
You'd literally be like, Oh, well, whatever I that up. And then it will be fine,
you know? But instead.
[Inaudible].
A disease. He just says the wickedly talented, the wooden only disease,
Aziz Ansari. Wow dude,
the Oscars are hilarious, dude.
When Brando brought up the, remember this I don't,
but it's a thing right here. When he went for a run.
Obviously.
You brought up an Indian woman, native American, whatever. I don't know how.
Hello. My name is Sasha middle feather. I'm a patchy.
And I'm president of the national native American affirmative image committee
representing Marlon Brando this evening to tell you in a
very long speech,
which I cannot share with you presently because of time.
But I will be glad to share with the press afterwards that he re very
regretfully,
cannot accept this very generous award and the
reasons for this being odd,
the treatment of American Indians today by the film industry,
excuse me. Wow.
Wow. Wow. People BU
trying to make a point here. People BU that dresses.
Movie reruns,
and also with recent happenings at wounded knee,
I begged at this time that I have not intruded upon the seasoning
and that we will in the future,
our hearts and our understandings will meet with love and
generosity. Thank you. On behalf of mom and Brando.
Dude, he didn't even show up and he was like, yo doing,
you'll go talk about wounded name.
If I get a Oscar dude, there's no way I'm going up to accept it.
I'm sending for real David Caruso and he's going to go
up and he's going to he's, you know, he's going to say, he's going to say,
sorry, but Chris D'Elia,
can't be here and he's going to say he wanted to,
but the buddy went to the doctor the other day and it turns out
he's just too sick with it.
And then he puts his glasses on and pivots and then that happens.
And then they say coming up
[inaudible] award for best cinematographer, dude. That will be the dude.
He went to the doctor the other day and it wasn't go home.
So I was on the wall and it turns out
he's too sick with it.
Yeah, dude.